In this new era of travel, there will be stricter hygiene standards...
...with hand sanitizers, face masks and social distancing becoming the norm.
The World Travel and Tourism Council says a coordinated response is key.
It is crucial to use the same standard protocols across the world...
...so that the traveler feels comfortable.
So, we could well see standardized cleaning and testing protocols...
...introduced around the world.
In airports, we'll likely see health screening processes...
...like temperature checks and COVID-19 tests.
Your in-flight experience may look a little different too,...
...with an increasing number of airlines telling passengers to wear face masks.
EasyJet is said to be looking into social distancing measures...
...such as leaving middle seats empty, and if air capacity is down...
...as a result, then the cost of travel could well go up.
At sea, cruises are talking about introducing one-way systems on board,...
...and it's unlikely you'll be able to find buffets in the post-COVID world.
They could become a thing of the past in hotels, too.